James Harris myth reorganizations become  necessary which results in the  termination of James Harris I'm getting  fired laid off but it's Christmas Eve  what was that  I always knew I would die an elevator I  will find you  fire you and then make sure that you are  fired from your next three jobs after  that hello hello I know we may just be  the last men and women on earth why  don't you help me get us both a d-x  employee shall not infringe upon the  workspace of company I need you to pray  for me  dear God if they're there he's there  dad's gonna kill me he finds out I was  fired laid off  there's no such thing as a question  without an answer you might not know it  now but it's out there waiting to be  found  and when you find it there's no feeling  like it in the world  Merry Christmas  says Antigua Madame Yvonne Violette  Susan says Anna's aunt is a sign of  involved of Allah in all five mr. hi  again I'm senior old van